I have one Central person that I was
trying to prove for a very long time
which was my father he disapproved of my
whole thing and for 5 years we didn't
talk very much and so he calls me up he
says hey you're going to want to sit
down for this and so he says I'm sorry
for everything like he's a middle
eastern father born in Iran where my
father was born women weren't allowed to
drive cars cars came with drivers with
them when you bought them he was born in
a very different world fathers don't
apologize to Sons it just wasn't that
way and I can see that now and so rather
than take it for the Olive Branch that
it was I said I didn't care about
opinion 5 years ago when I left and I
don't care now and he was like well
we'll see how long your success lasts
but the the main point there was that I
did everything that I've done to this
point to beat my father when I really
start thinking about it I'm like I like
who I am he raised me so doesn't that
mean that he might have been the perfect
father